[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
les bureaux de vote ont fermé en côte
d'ivoire les électeurs étaient appelés à
renouveler leurs députés quatre mois
après une présidentielle agitée le
scrutin s'est déroulé dans le calme
une élection à laquelle participent
l'ensemble de l'opposition depuis dix
ans l'opposition sénégalaise appel à
trois jours de manifestations le pays
connaît une flambée de violences depuis
l'arrestation d'opposants aux semaines
son corps au moins quatre personnes sont
mortes hier dans des affrontements entre
les forces de l'ordre et des centaines
de jeunes qui demandent sa libération en
soutien aux manifestants la diaspora
sénégal
rassemblés cet après midi à paris la
séquence devrait faire date dans
l'histoire des religions première
rencontre officielle entre le vatican et
le schisme au deuxième jour de son
voyage en irak est le premier de
l'histoire pour un pape
françois s'est entretenu avec le grand
ayatollah ali sistani
ce dernier fait part de son engagement
pour la paix et la sécurité des
chrétiens d'irak
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france jour
d'élection ce samedi en côte d'ivoire
près de 7 millions et demi d'électeurs
étaient appelés aux urnes les bureaux de
vote sont désormais fermés
un scrutin qui s'est déroulé dans le
calme porteur d'espoirs pour apaiser la
vie politique quatre mois après une
présidentielle marquées par des
violences et boycottées par l'opposition
est cette fois ci et pour la première
fois depuis dix ans à l'ensemble des
principaux acteurs politiques
participent à ces législatives dont la
formation de l'ancien président laurent
gbagbo
un retour qui ne passe pas inaperçu
quant à nos vielles comme un air de
revanche pour laurent gbagbo
alors que l'ancien président a dit il y
a dix ans refusé d'admettre sa défaite
lors de la présidentielle face à
alassane ouattara laurent gbagbo se
mobilisent pour faire basculer le
pouvoir en place à lausanne action en
prenant le pouvoir pour leur redonner à
tout endroit encore pouvoir malgré ses
démêlés avec la justice en 2011
l'ancien président est toujours très
populaire en côte d'ivoire et sa
nouvelle alliance avec le parti
démocratique pourrait lui donner
davantage
henri konan bédié qui a soutenu alassane
ouattara lors du précédent scrutin
législatif est désormais ralliés à la
cause du parti pro gbagbo pour empêcher
je cite la consolidation d'un pouvoir
absolu d'alassane ouattara et de son
parti un revirement de situation qui
dérange l'opposition cette élection est
une occasion pour faire le bilan
et surtout ceux passés au pouvoir
laissait on a vu ce qu'ils ont laissé
on a vu aussi ce que nous avons fait en
dix ans c'est ça le bilan
mais s'il continue à croire que le passé
le monde est le taz est resté fixe que
les jeunes n'ont pas changé dans les
attentes nous aurons en europe où les
illusions de ce soir si depuis dix ans
le parti d'alassane ouattara faisait
route seul vers le pouvoir
cette seconde élection législative
depuis la réforme constitutionnelle est
marquée par la présence des trois partis
majeurs du pays motivés à jouer le jeu
des urnes
l'alliance entre le parti pro gbagbo de
tendance socialiste et celui d'henri
konan bédié de tendance libérale de
leurs garanties pour autant pas la
victoire
et l'on peut s'attendre à une élection
disputée et nous sommes en direct avec
alafé wakili journaliste et directeur de
l'intelligent d'abidjan
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france est-ce que vous avez des premiers
chiffres concernant la participation par
exemple non et même sur les arbres n'est
pas auto izal étonné pendant le
dépouillement a donc commencé quels sont
les enjeux de ce scrutin pour le parti
du président ouattara
l'enjeu pour le parti du pédiatre à ces
deux derniers d'avoir la majorité qui
l'a déjà l'enjeu c'est de contenir
consolidé confirmé cette majorité dans
un contexte plus ouvert plus
concurrentiel qu'il y a cinq
un scrutin qui est marqué par le grand
retour du front populaire ivoirien le
parti de l'ancien président laurent
gbagbo après dix ans d'absence
c'est déjà là une marque d'apéro pour la
vie politique ivoirienne
oui c'est une grande marque d'apaisement
ce que cette fois ci contre le mans au
31 octobre 2020 on n'est pas allés aux
élections la peur au ventre ne se
demande pas si le scrutin aurait lieu
qu'est ce qui va se passer à l'issue du
scrutin est à un peu plus de calme et
d'apaisement
et c'est un élément important est aussi
faut signaler que le
il a dit aujourd'hui que c'est vrai que
c'est la première participation du f
pays depuis dix ans mais il faut aussi
dire que depuis 1995 et depuis 1995 la
première élection à laquelle participent
les grands partis politiques qui variait
es payé le pdci et le rdr dernière hdp
l'une des élections législatives de
cette nature-là la dernière a eu lieu en
1995 et oulémas quelques cinq ans plus
tard en 2000 après le coup d'état le rdr
de l'époque d'avoir participé à
l'élection législative alors les deux ex
présidents henri konan bédié laurent
gbagbo qui est appelé à la désobéissance
civile et boycotté la présidentielle il
ya quelques mois ne reconnaissent
toujours pas la réélection d'alassane
ouattara un troisième mandat comment
expliquer qu'ils ont pourtant décidé de
participer à cette élection législative
la reconnaissance et à deux niveaux il
ya des reconnaissance de fait de facto
et puis bon il ya peut-être eu
connaissance verbal est aussi on prédit
une forme de reconnaissance qui vit qui
est une des connaissances juridiques
parce que lorsque l'on pâtissier à
l'élection c'est reconnaissance de fait
une reconnaissance politique
et lorsque l'on contact avec un
gouvernement issu de l'élection du
président ouattara
ça une valeur juridique qui est
incontestable maintenant la
reconnaissance qui n'existe pas il est
peut-être d'autres verbale et morale
c'est à dire que du point de vue
intellectuel du point de vue de la
parole on voit du point de vue moral et
individuelles on estime qu'on ne
reconnaît pas mais dans les faits dans
la pratique du haut niveau les
agissements politiques et en termes de
valeur juridique
il ya une reconnaissance qui est là il
ya une acceptation guerra qui vaut ce
que ça vaut maintenant après on verra ce
que cela va donner un thème d'apaisement
lorsque ils vont se rencontrer à nouveau
lorsque le président gbagbo va rentrer
etc etc
ah merde je pense que il faut sortir de
ce débat de reconnaître
avec colette c'est pas l'essentiel est
le parti de laurent gbagbo et celui
d'henri konan bédié se sont engagés dans
une nouvelle alliance électorale a nommé
ensemble pour la démocratie et la
souveraineté les deux parties espèrent
remporter ensemble une majorité des 250
sièges
est ce que cette alternative est
plébiscité par la population ivoirienne
comment réagit-elle on verra ce soir
mais les premières estimations laissent
entendre que le premier tendance
laissant tant qu'il n'y a pas eu un raz
de marée dans les unes ya pas une
affluence massive
les gens se sont pas bousculés pour
aller voter c'est qui est quand même
étonnant on verra le fait que le fpr
rejoint d'élection c'est qu'il n'avait
pas fait depuis 2011 et en 2016 on verra
comment cela va impacter la
participation par rapport à 2011
lors des législatives par rapport à 2007
désista thibout il n'y avait que les
parties de bédié ouattara ensemble à
l'époque où opposé on verra comment la
présence du camp gbabo va épater vos
lectures et le taux de participation
c'est aussi l'un des enjeux l'un des
indicateurs au délà de la majorité ou
l'opposition ou de la majorité pour le
rhdp au pouvoir un tout dernier mot
concernant la cour pénale internationale
qui en janvier 2019 a acquitté en
première instance
laurent gbagbo elle a jusqu'au 31 mars
pour décider d'un éventuel procès en
appel est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un
coup de théâtre et qu'elle serait
l'incidence sur la situation dans le
pays
l'incidence on ne sait pas
les partisans de l'awb du présent d'une
date a été annoncée mais je pense qu'il
faudra attendre jusqu'au 31 mars mais
mars avait été dit qu est il n'en sera
rien attendant tout rose jusqu'au 31
mars
reste possible on ne peut pas seulement
spéculer sur le coup les terres qu on
peut penser aussi que y aura
confirmation des premières décision dont
encore lui je ne serais dit ce qui
pourrait se passer en cas de coup d'état
non merci d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
alafé wakili je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste à directeur de l'intelligent
d'abidjan le sénégal en proie à de
violents troubles depuis l'arrestation
de l'opposant ousman sonko les pires
émeutes depuis plusieurs années et la
situation ne devrait pas s'améliorer
le mouvement de défense de la démocratie
qui regroupe des opposants au président
macky sall appel ce dimanche les
sénégalais à descendre dans la rue et
pendant trois jours à compter de lundi
les affrontements de ces derniers jours
entre manifestants et forces de l'ordre
ont déjà fait au moins cinq morts
walid ben ali qui m'a rossi
une situation presque hors de contrôle
depuis mercredi 3 mars la jeunesse
sénégalaise s'insurge contre les actions
des forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons malheureusement le centre non
à la guerre puis vers lacrymogènes ils
bombardent les gens veulent pas qu'on
aurait alors nous allons parler à une
zone non aucune forme de violence
l'arrestation du principal opposant
politique ousman sonko a déclenché la
colère de plusieurs de ses supporters
[Applaudissements]
nous voulons mais nous avons besoin de
la liberté
en quoi c'est tout le troisième homme à
la présidentielle de 2010 9 arrêté
officiellement pour trouble à l'ordre
public alors qu'il était en chemin pour
répondre à une convocation d'un tribunal
ousman sonko accusé de viol et menaces
de mort par une employée de salons de
massage
le député présenter finalement à un juge
vendredi a été de nouveau mise en garde
à vue jusqu'à ce dimanche dans la
dernière procédure pour trouble à
l'ordre public
ousman sonko sera donc présenté à un
nouveau juge lundi
le gouvernement a informé qu'il
prendrait toutes les dispositions
nécessaires au maintien de l'ordre
public
les locaux de plusieurs médias proches
du pouvoir ont été visés tout comme les
devantures de plusieurs enseignes
françaises
coupable d'avoir diffusé des images de
violences
les signaux de deux chaînes de
télévision privées ont été suspendus par
le gouvernement
et à paris une manifestation en soutien
au choix ne sont qu auprès a eu lieu cet
après midi
compte rendu de notre reporter thomas
bonnin plusieurs centaines de
manifestants réunis depuis le début de
ce samedi après midi ici place de la
république pour afficher leur opposition
au président sénégalais macky sall avec
des slogans hostiles qui sont lancées à
son encontre macky sall démission macky
sall dégage voilà ce qu'on peut entendre
de la part de cette foule qui s'est
également rassemblée pour apporter leur
soutien aux manifestants qui sont au
sénégal en ce moment il est d'ailleurs
eu un hommage tout à l'heure avec une
minute de silence
les manifestants qui ont posé le genou à
terre pour rendre hommage aux
manifestants qui ont perdu la vie ces
derniers jours dans les rues sénégalaise
alors évidemment ils demandent aussi la
libération des prisonniers et en premier
lieu desquelles celle douce fans sont qu
un des leader de l'opposition au sénégal
qui est en garde à vue jusqu'à ce
dimanche tous ici ne sont pas forcément
des partisans d'ousmane sont qu
initialement mais il s'inquiète des
dérives anti démocratiques en cours en
ce moment au sénégal propose d'écouter
le représentant du parti d'ousmane sont
qu en france au micro de matisse marc
deros quelles sont les informations que
vous avez dernièrement de ce qui se
passe à la fois pour ousman sonko et
plus généralement au sénégal enfants bat
plus généralement on voit pression'
égale aujourd'hui vie
un des moments les plus sombres de son
histoire parce qu'il ya on enregistre
depuis ce matin six morts des gens qui
sont tués dans le sud par l'armée à bout
portant
on nous apprend même ce matin que
l'armée sénégalaise rentrer même va même
cueillir des gens dans leur domicile
pour eux parce qu'ils ont eu le tort de
manifester hier ils ont eu du tueur de
voir deux des frères qui ont été tués
lâche moi si je puis dire par le
président en place les régimes et tout
ça pour un troisième mandat que les
sénégalais ne seront acceptés une
contestation qui dépasse donc la simple
personnalité d'ousmane sont comme
beaucoup ici s'inquiète du recul
démocratique dans ce pays dont la
réputation est celle d'un pays stable en
afrique de l'ouest certains demandent
également des comptes aux gouvernements
occidentaux et au gouvernement français
en particulier puisque certains ici
dénonce une forme de complicité entre le
gouvernement français et les élites au
sénégal notamment ce qui concerne
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
najaf ville sainte du monde chiite
au deuxième jour de sa visite en irak
c'est ici que le pape françois s'est
entretenu ce samedi avec le grand
ayatollah ali sistani références
religieuses des chiites d'irak et du
monde
une rencontre très privé de près d'une
heure une rencontre historique c'est la
première fois que le vatican et
changeait officiellement avec le schisme
à l'issue de ce huis clos l'ayatollah
sistani s'est engagé à garantir la paix
la sécurité et tous les droits aux
chrétiens d'irak
le récit de france what is rich
[Musique]
première visite d'un chef de l'église
catholique en irak
une visite de trois jours aux enjeux
politiques multiples tout d'abord le
pape souhaite conforter les chrétiens
dans le pays mais aussi dans la région
une communauté très fragilisée depuis
2014 avec l'avènement de dèche et ses
innombrables massacre à l'encontre des
chrétiens d'orient
le pape françois exhorte à l'arrêt des
extrémismes et des violences il est
indispensable d'assurer la participation
de tous les groupes politiques sociaux
et religieux et de garantir les droits
fondamentaux de tous les citoyens que se
taisent les armes que la diffusion soit
limitée ici et partout que cessent les
intérêts partisans ses intérêts
extérieurs ci se désintéresse de la
population locale assez de violence et
d'extrémisme deux factions d'intolérance
pour le vatican l'un des enjeux de
taille et de poursuivre voire renouer le
dialogue avec le monde musulman
la communauté chiite en l'occurrence une
étape importante du voyage du souverain
pontife la rencontre ce samedi dans la
ville sainte de nadjaf avec l'ayatollah
ali sistani figure la plus importante du
chiisme irakien présenté comme un modéré
le pape françois temps donc la main aux
chiites après l'avoir tendue aux
sunnites avec l'egypte en 2017
c'est une certaine unité entre toutes
les religions
cette visite est un événement
considérable qui doit remettre l'irak
sur la carte du monde civilisé estime le
ministre irakien de la culture à sanaa m
le pays est en effet toujours en proie
au terrorisme
un double attentat revendiqué par des
chats fait 32 morts sur un marché de
bagdad le 21 janvier dernier
il est donc plus que jamais nécessaire
d'inverser la tendance en irak
/ plus d'une décennie de guerre et c'est
avec cette visite notamment l'objectif
du président irakien barham saleh pour
l'irak enfin
l'autre enjeu d'avenir majeur de cette
visite est économique et touristique
la pré visite est encore plus importante
que la visite les lieux historiques et
religieux où se rendra le pape en
particulier urbe re-so d'abraham sont
les sites touristiques qui peuvent faire
la prospérité de l'irak de demain des
objectifs qui réclament une sécurité
sans faille et une stabilité politique
qui pour le moment font encore gravement
défaut un directeur général de médecins
chrétiens d'orient benjamin blanchard
revient sur l'enjeu de cette visite
papale
oren il s'agit tout simplement je crois
de la première visite de ce genre pas
seulement de papin des deux n'a porte
quel chef d'état depuis l'invasion
américaine de 2003 ce n'est pas une
visite surprise une visite en cachette
comme c'est souvent le cas pour les
chefs d'état occidentaux
c'est une visite annoncée longtemps la
vence depuis trois mois
et puis également une particularité
c'est que le pape se rend vraiment de
partout on l'a vu à léa ou qu'on l'a vu
aller à nadjaf là aujourd'hui il doit se
rendre à mossoul qui après dans la
plaine de ninive
et puis ensuite à erbil qui fait quelque
chose que ni les chefs d'état étrangers
n'est en en fait depuis 2003 et ni même
les officiels irakiens parce que il faut
dire qu'il ya très peu de visites sur le
terrain du premier ministre des premiers
ministres successifs notamment
donc c'est vraiment très important à la
fois pour l'irak qui peut être fier de
cette visite et surtout si elle va j'en
suis sûr se dérouler correctement sans
problèmes sécuritaires majeurs etc
et puis également pour les chrétiens
puisque ce sont eux qui sont à l'origine
de ce voyage notamment le patriarche des
chaldéens louis raphaël sakho et ce
voyage est en train d'être une grande
réussite donc ça sera un grand atout
pour les chrétiens
elle nikol pashinian on doit partir le
cri de colère d'une partie des arméniens
ils réclament la démission du premier
ministre contesté depuis la défaite
militaire dans le haut-karabagh face à
l'azerbaïdjan
le chef du gouvernement qui dénonçait il
ya quelques jours une tentative de coup
d'état militaire après l'appel au départ
lancé par le chef de l'armée
ses opposants se sont une nouvelle fois
rassemblés ce samedi devant le parlement
on retrouve à erevan notre envoyé
spécial david khalifa des milliers de
manifestantes une nouvelle fois défilé à
dans les rues de yerevan afin de
réclamer le départ de nikol pashinian le
cortège s'est élancé du parlement
arménien pour venir la terminer sa
course
ici place de la république où se tient
le bureau du premier ministre arménien
cette mobilisation s'est faite à l'appel
de vazguen manouchian l'une des
principales figures de l'opposition
arménienne
il était temps en tête de cortège pour
venir apporter son soutien à ces
manifestants et qui considère nikol
pashinian comme responsable de la
défaite militaire dans le haut karabagh
est vécue comme une véritable
humiliation nationale pour la plupart à
de ses partisans anti pashinian je vous
propose d'en écouter quelques uns j'ai
du mal à dire ce que l'opposition
obtiendra avec ce rassemblement parce
que pour prévoir les résultats possibles
d'événements politiques
les opposants qui doivent aussi être des
acteurs politiques
je pense et ce n'est pas que mon avis
c'est un fait que les autorités
politiques de la république représentés
par un seul dirigeant politique qui
s'accroche à son poste de premier
ministre
nikol pashinian or ils ne sont pas des
acteurs politiques
oui j'ai écrit la chanson mon art sac
mon armée ni la musique ainsi que les
paroles
les gens l'ont beaucoup aimé sans doute
le secret de la popularité de cette
chanson réside dans le fait qu'elle est
écoutée tant par l'opposition que par
des partisans de nikol pashinian ces
derniers ne partagent bien sûr pas cette
chanson sur leur page mais je sais
qu'ils écoutent ils en parlent ils
admirent c'est le moins que je puisse
faire pour l'opposition dont je suis
membre
[Musique]
aucun débordement à signaler lors de
cette mobilisation encadrés par un
important dispositif de sécurité
plus tôt dans la journée vers 13 heures
heure locale un autre rassemblement
s'est tenu cette fois ci devant le
ministère de la défense
plusieurs centaines de militaires et
d'anciens militaires sont venus apporter
leur soutien au chef d'état major de
l'armée qui a été démis officiellement à
2 c à fonctions ce vendredi
elle vous proposant d'écouter
quelques-uns l'eau tout d'abord nous
représentons l'union des officiers de
réserve de la république d'arménie
elle s'appelle bouclier de la patrie je
propose aux jeunes ont su retrouver
richard roca nous sommes ici pour
soutenir nos amis la haute direction des
forces armées qui actuellement font
littéralement l'objet d'une persécution
anticonstitutionnel sort en dessous nous
voulons faire comprendre que les
officiers des forces armées qu'il soit
en service ou de réserve serre les rangs
ils sont aux côtés de leur commandement
on y donne cinq hommes entre eux je suis
venu en tant qu'officier de réserve afin
d'exprimer mon soutien à l'état major et
à tous les officiers et généraux haut
placé qui ont signé la demande de l'état
major
concernant la démission de l'homme qui
occupe le poste de premier ministre de
notre pays
je soutiens totalement cette initiative
de plus je trouve même qu'elle a un peu
trop tarder écoutez l'obligé à quitter
son poste
ça sonne de façon étrange ce n'est pas
une boutique un magasin de porcelaine ou
une ébénisterie et est animé bel
fabricant
vous avez entendu beaucoup de colère
envers nikol pashinian qui considérait
un seul chef d'état major de l'armée
comme responsable de la tentative du
coup d'état et qu'il y avait eu la
semaine dernière un selon les mots de
nikol pashinian en tout cas le premier
ministre arménien tente de trouver des
solutions
puisque hier il a rencontré à l'une des
figures de l'opposition parlementaire
afin d'éluder elle la question à
d'élections législatives anticipées afin
de pouvoir à trouver une solution à
cette crise politique qui s'enlise ici
en arménie aux états unis qu'à new york
les salles de cinéma ouvert fermé depuis
mi mars en raison de la pandémie
elles peuvent depuis vendredi accueillir
à nouveau du public capacité d'accueil
restreinte port du masque ou encore
respect des mesures barrières un début
de retour à la normale cadré mais
encourageant grâce taya les salles
obscures retrouve la lumière
à l'entrée on peut lire welcome back ou
content de vous revoir
un message que les cinéphiles de big
apple n'ont pas attendu de lire pour se
ruer dans les salles
je me sens excitée et heureuse
je me sens bien en fait je suis
infirmier je viens de quitter mon
travail
vous savez revenir un an plus tard je
m'occupe du coc vidé de tout ça et je
suis content de revenir au cinéma le
crépitement et l'odeur du pop corn
rien de tel pour oublier le coc vide le
temps d'une séance 1 depuis le 17 mars
2020 toutes les salles de la capitale
américaine ont été contraintes de fermer
par un décret du maire bill de blasio et
c'est ce lundi que le gouverneur de
l'état andrew cuomo a annoncé la bonne
nouvelle avec bien évidemment des
mesures à respecter
réservation de sa place en ligne jauge à
25% de la capacité soit 50 personnes par
salle maximum port du masque obligatoire
distanciation social nettoyage des
salles entre chaque séance et
ventilation améliorée pour certaines
malgré ces contraintes c'est une
véritable bouffée d'oxygène pour les new
yorkais
j'ai entendu dire que les salles ouvrait
pour la première fois
et je suis tellement là c'est de
m'asseoir sur mon canapé et de regarder
des films en streaming
alors je suis sorti de la maison et
bizarrement j'ai été attiré par un film
qui traite du désespoir et de l'
isolement
mais pourquoi pas après tout c'est le
bémol peut des blockbusters sont pour
l'instant à la fiche
les studios hollywoodiens ayant décalé
la majorité des films à gros budget
ajoutez à cela les mesures de
restriction qui ont contraint certaines
salles à rester fermés néanmoins comme
ce directeur certains veulent rester
positif une fois que le film commencera
les lumières vont s'éteindre ce sera
comme dans toutes les autres grandes
expériences théâtrales que vous avez
vécu mais avant et après ce sera un peu
différent toutes les places sont
réservées
ce qui signifie qu'il n'ya pas de files
d'attentes pour les meilleures places
vous choisissez vos places en ligne
et puis une autre différence c'est qu'il
n'y aura pas de gens autour de vous à
boire et à manger sans masquer des
points encourageants mais reste à savoir
si ces réouvertures en capacité réduite
seront économiquement viable pour ces
salles qui voit en cette réouverture
une première étape cruciale dans la
relance de leur activité
et c'est la fin d'un thé mission merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actu dont une trentaine de minutes à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du technique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose dit jim jones étaient
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit qui doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]